today on the matt well show
detransitioners are speaking out to tell
their horrifying stories revealing the
reality of so-called gender affirmation
surgery but trans activists and big tech
are conspiring to silence these voices
as always also pro-abortion terrorists
are promising to ramp up their campaign
of violence and intimidation as we rate
the decision on roe and ben shapiro
causes controversy by claiming that
disney has a gay agenda even though
disney admits
that it has a gay agenda plus a star nfl
quarterback speaks out against the
scourge of quote-unquote crazy guns in
our daily cancellation a tick-tock star
complains after being turned away from a
horse ranch because she exceeds the
weight limit for horses well whose fault
is that we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
gas prices you have noticed are terribly
high they're only going to get more uh
even worse as the summer drags on and
but here's the here's the good news
there's an incredible app everyone who
buys gas needs to know about it's called
upside my listeners are earning cash
back for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh for
25 cents per gallon or more on your
first fill up getting that cash back
it's as easy as that don't pay full
price to the pump anymore get cash back
using upside just download the app for
free use promo code walsh for 25 cents
per gallon or more on your first tank
and by the way it's not just for gas you
can earn cash back at grocery stores
restaurants you can use it with take out
and you can cash out any time to your
bank account or an e-gift card for
select retailers and brands so it's very
easy to do uh
no effort goes into it at all and you're
making money back there's just there's
no downside to this it's all upside just
download the free upside app and use
promo code walsh for 25 cents per gallon
or more cash back on your first tank
just use my promo code walsh again
that's code walsh
well some of the most powerful voices in
the battle against gender ideology are
the de-transitioners people who have
gone through the quote-unquote gender
transition process seen it up close
experienced it firsthand and then turned
around to go back
but the great tragedy in these stories
is that as they turn around to head back
in the other direction they find that
the drawbridge has been lifted their
return route has been taken away because
there's no way to fully get back to
where they were before who they were
before um
they were lured across the bridge and
then trapped there
damage that was done is permanent
they cannot entirely reclaim the body
and identity that has been taken from
them but they can shout to anyone else
who might cross the bridge to warn them
to tell them to you know not to come
here it's a trap
and that's why their voices are so
powerful it's one thing for those of us
who've
never crossed the bridge to point to it
and say well don't go there you don't
want to see what's on the other side
but it's another thing for the people
who've actually crossed it to say the
same because if you're really determined
to fool yourself
you might dismiss the people on your
side of the bridge who've never seen the
other side but it's very difficult to
dismiss the people who've been there
and can give you first-hand accounts of
the horror that awaits you
so yesterday i read to you uh one of one
of these stories a de-transitioned male
who goes by the handle tulip r on
twitter and is a member of the group
called
genspect which is an organization of
parents medical professionals and d
transitioners warning about the
realities of these frankenstein
butchery procedures
the story that he shared is like all
such stories
harrowing and horrifying no matter how
many times you read them you still just
sit there
dumbstruck
sort of unable to believe that this is
actually happening and that peop that
this is that that
we are doing this to people
he says that he's been left mutilated
with no sexual function unable to even
use the bathroom normally
he's now overcome by grief and anger all
the time
furious at the people who did this to
him and rightly so
he was apparently an adult when he
underwent the genital mutilation
procedures but that doesn't relieve the
doctors of their moral and professional
responsibilities
they should have treated his mental
afflictions but instead they carved up
his body to conform it to his deluded
mental state and they did that for money
that's that's the reason that they did
it
there's no defending that
but
why defend it when you can just silence
for years the d transitioners were
simply
chased off to the margins ignored by
almost everybody they spoke out but
nobody would listen
now that's starting to change people are
listening
which which means the left has to resort
to other tactics
and that's why without explanation
twitter has been going through this
man's uh twitter thread and deleting the
most shocking details from his account
they're just going through and saying no
no one's allowed to see that part of
this
he confirmed that the deleted tweets in
the thread were not deleted by him
twitter made that decision for instance
as an archive of the thread shows one of
the tweets that twitter deleted said
quoting i said i tore a sutra four days
post recovery they promised to address
it i begged them in emails to fix it
they scorned me instead
years later i have what looks like a
chunk of missing flesh next to my
neo-vagina it literally looks like
someone hacked at me they still won't
fix it
by the way this is very consistent with
the kind of thing we heard from scott
nugent in our film what is a woman
um
and what she told us is similar in the
sense now that's a female to male this
in this case male to female but
similar in the sense that what scott
nuja told us is that
you experience all these
problems
from this procedure and the people who
did it to you are not going to help you
they just don't care
because here's the thing if they cared
about you if they had any compassion for
you if they cared about your well-being
they never would have done this to you
in the first place
so it's not in their interest to try to
help you after the fact
um they're not apparently legally
required to do so and so they're just
not gonna because they want to pretend
that you don't exist that's the thing if
once you go through this
and it's um
and you're dealing with all these
problems well you don't exist anymore as
far as they're concerned
here's another detail that twitter
doesn't want you to see because they
deleted it
uh he wrote and if you if you do take
testosterone after being post-op
you run the risk of internal hair in the
neo-vagina imagine dealing with internal
hair growth growth after everything what
a choice
be healthy on testosterone and a freak
or remain a sexless eunuch
now trans activists mass reported the
thread to stop people from seeing it and
twitter has apparently obliged by slowly
deleting the most shocking details from
it there's no argument this is hate
speech or misinformation he's simply
reporting his own experiences
his lived experiences i thought they're
supposed to care about lived experience
trans activists don't want you to see it
because they're hiding the truth and
they know that they're hiding it
you know one of the questions i get
asked a lot in interviews is um
whether the gender ideologues featured
and what is a woman are actually
confused and deluded or are they being
intentionally deceptive is this insanity
or malice
and the answer was pretty clear to me
while filming it and has become all the
more clear since its release this is
malice
now there's a fair amount of insanity
mixed into this picture here part of one
of the ingredients that that goes into
the pot but
they know what they're doing
they know that most of what they say is
nonsense they know that they have no
defense and so
they silence
the censorship efforts have been ramped
up significantly over the last few weeks
it seems to me in fact
at the same time that twitter has been
combing through d transition or tweets
to delete the most problematic stuff
problematic to their agenda anyway
they've also banned a journalist named
savannah hernandez now
they never gave an explanation for her
ban this is not the first time that
she's been banned
but perhaps uh one is not needed here's
the last video she posted before they
booted her she's at a this is a she's at
a pride march interviewing people
almost all young people
about their own personal
self-identification that's all she's
doing and she got banned but here's the
video
um i'm gay
what age did you know that you were gay
um
i think at like 10 i knew that i
i think at 10 but i wasn't like
i wasn't clear on my gender
yeah i
i think it was around like
10 as well when i started questioning if
i was bi and then since then it was kind
of like a
slippery slope because i kept i was like
am i bi omni lesbian and then i i kind
of like
came to the point and now recently i've
been like in my pan but then i like i
think
now i'm starting to realize that i'm
queer but yeah it was it started around
10. it wasn't like
fully
formed but i guess like that's when i
realized wait
that's a possibility
yeah i am genderqueer trans mask and
queer what's trans mask trans mask is
like people under the non-binary
umbrella at identifying like or
presenting mask
yeah what about you
um
i'm trans and uh
on my sexuality is unlabeled
um
i use he him pronouns yeah and i used
today pronouns tell us what you guys
identify as we're asking everyone here
today
gay
gay cis
what is it cisgender male there we go i
don't know
gender
gender neutral or gender fluid i think
that's what they said i don't know i'm
confused
do you identify as gender fluid
i don't know
see her
it i feel like honestly honestly it
should not be a bad thing like i've
talked to people who go with they and
them i'm like well in the grammar of
things how would you want to represent
yourselves like i mean i guess it
well it's obvious why they don't want
anyone to see that as we discovered with
what is a woman the most damning thing
you can do to an lgbt activist is just
let them talk
there's nothing you can say to them that
will condemn or discredit them more than
their own words
and in this case we see how these people
though they're marching for pride
don't have any concept of their own
identity i mean what are they proud of
exactly
they're simply rattling off a list of
labels they clearly don't understand
themselves but you can't blame them for
not understanding labels because labels
like pan and omni and cis
don't mean anything anyway it's all
gibberish
finally we hear from one guy who
identifies as an it
he has dehumanized himself he refers to
himself as an object
a thing
though we should give him credit for
some measure of honesty after all a
person with
no gender
if such a person existed which they
don't but if they did and if that's what
you're pretending you are
then you would indeed be in it not as
they they refer to multiple people it
refers to an individual thing
that can't be otherwise defined or
labeled i mean if you if you were
walking along and you found a strange
ominous looking like object laying on
the ground
you would shout to the person standing
next to you don't go near it
that would be grammatically correct
though it's deeply psychologically
unhealthy for a person to see themselves
that way
this is what the lgbt cult has become
people don't
find themselves or express their true
identities when they fall prey to it
rather they they lose themselves they
lose any firm notion that they are a
self
they get lost in this disorienting fog
where every
person has a million labels and none of
the labels really mean anything
these are not people proud of their
identities these are people without
identities
they don't know who they are or even
what they are
that's what happens with the so-called
gender affirmation
surgeries
the butchery the mutilation
you're male you want to be a woman
you're never going to be a woman
but what you can do is remove
the outward markers of your own manhood
so you can you can take that away from
yourself
and then you're just stuck in this kind
of limbo as these detransitioners tell
us
and that's why
all you have to do is reveal it just let
these people talk for five seconds to
see it which is why these kinds of
videos and the people who make them must
be just wiped out
we should note that ali beth stuckey was
also suspended this week for criticizing
that fox segment about the trans toddler
meanwhile libs of tick tock who's been
on a crusade of the last few weeks to
expose all the drag events for kids that
we've talked about on this show
has now been inundated with death
threats by people telling her
stop posting this stuff or i'm gonna
kill you
as you know i received similar treatment
after we released my film this is how
desperate these people are they're
backed into a corner
they're surrounded on all sides by their
own incoherence and moral insanity they
backed themselves into that corner we
didn't put them there
so they're lashing out they're running
scared
the truth is catching up to them
all they have left to do is threaten
and censor
but it's not going to work
the truth will be made known
one way or another
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well those of you who saw my barbecue
tiktok reaction video a couple weekends
ago know that i i love grilling up good
ranchers for my family and uh reacting
to tick-tock videos too i guess i like
both of those things equally
i suppose well grilling season is
officially upon us that's a good news
and if you're looking for the perfect
cuts of american beef chicken and
seafood this summer you should check out
good ranchers as well maybe leave the
tick tock out of it just stick with the
good rangers my family eats good
ranchers because they deliver right to
your door once you subscribe your price
is locked in for good and if that wasn't
enticing enough good ranchers is giving
away two free rib eyes a hundred dollar
value to my listeners for a limited time
only and you heard that right just go to
goodranchers.com
choose my promo code walsh to get two 18
ounce prime center cut rib eyes free
with your order i can tell you just like
everything good ranchers has they are
delicious you don't want to miss out on
this offer it's a limited time offer so
don't miss uh other places will charge
you over fifty dollars per stake for rib
eyes like these good ranchers is giving
two of them away for free these are usda
prime 100 american steakhouse quality
cuts of beef just go to goodranchers.com
walsh and claim your rib eyes today
before they run out take my advice break
up with grocery store meet shop good
ranchers today
speaking of making threats you know word
on the street was that the supreme court
would release its road decision today um
that didn't end up happening i mean it's
been a couple weeks now of uh there's a
slate of decisions they're going to
announce and then everyone thinks
they're going to announce a row and then
they don't
i believe that today was the last
day they had on the schedule officially
to release decisions but they still
didn't release this one
so uh they go on break
starting in july which means i don't
know maybe they'll wait for the very
last day of june and just announce the
decision
skip out of town as soon as possible and
go hide somewhere can't really blame
them for that i mean after all there was
a crazy leftist who showed up at
kavanaugh's house to assassinate him so
i'm sure all of that is being factored
in
um
and
uh and they want to get out you know i
say they want to get out of town before
the protest but when we say protest we
really mean terrorism because that's
what the left is doing here
as reported by the post-millennial says
pro-abortion militant group jane's
revenge has declared that their 30 days
of patience and mercy
have come to an end
in an open letter they said your 30 days
expired yesterday we offered an
honorable way out
you could have walked away now the leash
is off and we will make it as hard as
possible for your campaign of oppression
to continue
it's not exactly clear who they're
talking i guess they're just talking to
they're talking to pro-lifers in general
just all of us
is who this threat is being um
made against
we have demonstrated in the past month
how easy and fun it is to attack we are
versatile
uh we are mercurial and we answer to no
one but ourselves
we promise to take increasingly drastic
actions against oppressive
infrastructures rest assured that we
will and those measures may come in the
form of something so easily cleaned up
as a fire and graffiti sometimes you
will see what we do and you will know
that it is us sometimes you will think
you merely are unlucky because you
cannot see the ways which we interfere
in your affairs but your pointless
attempts to control others and make life
more difficult will not be met passively
um the group takes responsibility post
millennial reports for recent attacks on
pregnancy and pro-life centers
in um madison in uh madison wisconsin
colorado massachusetts washington iowa
north carolina there's there was a
couple attacks in uh in washington
new york florida
more attacks in washington morton
texas oregon
so they've already committed these
attacks mostly vandalism of pro-life
centers pregnancy centers and now
they're threatening to do more
this of course is not getting a lot of
attention in the media i mean you have a
you have a terrorist organization
openly making threats
and
like pretending to be these these like
comic book super villains do what we
want or there will be more attacks
and uh and they're doing this and it's
the media is just ignoring it
as always
because if they don't ignore it then
they'll have to admit that um that an
awful lot of the domestic terrorism we
see in this country happens on the left
when their narrative of course is that
it never happens the left it's all
right-wing violence
i can't remember the last time we had
something like this from our right wing
group
staging a string of attacks coordinated
attacks all across the country
and openly threatening to do more if
they don't get what they want
which in this case of course even if you
scare a bunch of pregnancy centers and
pro-life centers
that's not going to do anything to stop
roe v wade from being overturned
and just think about how
this this is not breaking news given who
these people are and they support
killing babies but think about how evil
you have to be
to go after a pregnancy center
you know what pregnancy centers do
um this might surprise you if you're
relying on you know the left to tell you
for your information especially about
pregnancy centers but no they don't they
don't go out and like kidnap
women
and force them to have babies okay they
don't they don't do that
all they do is offer
resources
to women who are
oftentimes having you know
crisis pregnancies
and the interesting thing is that that's
exactly what the left
says we don't do right
they say oh well you only care you're
you're only pro-birth you're not
pro-life
you don't actually care you don't care
about women you don't care about the
babies
once the baby's born you don't care
about the about the baby
well that's exactly what pregnancy
centers do they care for women they
provide resources to women
and they also care for the babies once
the babies are born
so on one hand we don't do this this is
this doesn't exist on the other hand
we we do this and it's bad and uh if
you're one in one of these organizations
then you know
there's gonna be terrorist attacks
against your facilities
i guess if you burn all the pregnancy
centers down then you can claim that
this doesn't exist and nobody does it
yet because you burned them all down
but i think when it comes to this kind
of thing there's a balance we have to
strike
with um people like jane's revenge i
feel the same way about the antifa nerds
on the one hand
these are terrorists and and they should
be arrested and prosecuted to the full
extent of the law they are dangerous in
the sense that anybody can be dangerous
even a nerd can be dangerous we've seen
that
so
that's the case on one hand
but on the other hand we should also be
clear that these people are
pathetic and ridiculous
and weak
and cowardly
and they're not going to scare anybody
away from the pro-life position
i'm not scared i don't know about you
are you scared of of jane's revenge
we will rain down our wrath upon you
okay go ahead
you're not scaring anybody we're you
know what we're doing we're laughing in
your face
that's what we're doing
and what's more they want uh they're
promising a summer of chaos right and
violence and everything and that's what
they want they want just chaos as soon
as the roe v wade is is announced as
soon as the decision is uh is announced
and rose overturned
they want chaos and violence all across
the country they're doing everything
they can to
promote that to encourage it
but um
and i could be wrong about this maybe
i'll eat my words i don't think it's
gonna happen
i think once rose is announced there's
going to be some there's going to be
more of this kind of vandalism and that
sort of thing
which is really bad and as i said should
be prosecuted
though i suspect that law enforcement a
lot of these cities where this is
happening aren't exactly going out of
their way to track down the people
responsible but they should be
prosecuted full extent of the law but i
think that's what it's going to be
there's going to be a vandalism more of
that
there might be some outbursts here and
there of rioting but i suspect probably
not even that
again i could be wrong
but i don't think there's going to be
even one riot in response to row being
overturned
i think groups like this on the left are
going to do everything they can to get
that going get the wheels turning but i
don't really think it's going to happen
because
um
as i've been saying the the the dirty
little secret here
is that actually um
most americans are pretty apathetic
about this issue
really they don't care that much
and they kind of fall down right down in
the middle of the abortion issue now
there really is no middle there is no
um comprehensible coherent middle
position on abortion does that doesn't
really exist either
the child in the womb is a human being
is a person
or not and there's no there's no in
between there
and if the child is a person as a human
being
then
that human being should have human
rights the same human rights that any
any of the rest of us have
so there doesn't really exist a middle
position
even so most americans are looking for
that middle position that doesn't exist
they're mostly apathetic about this
they shouldn't be i mean people should
care deeply
on the pro-life side of it
but this is something that even
pro-lifers have run into now we're not
out there trying to encourage violence
but we are trying to get people to care
about this issue more than they than
they do
and we've had a lot of success in that
regard but i think still most people are
basically
they just see to somebody doesn't affect
their lives that much
and that's going to work against the
left in this case because what they're
going to want is just
months and months of outrage what they
want is what we saw in 2020 with the blm
riots
and i don't think they're gonna get it
all right
so ben shapiro is in trouble again he's
been trending on twitter for a tweet
that he posted very offensive tweet
i am personally troubled by it
in fact i i disavow
this tweet and ben shapiro right here
right now ben tweeted in response to a
this is a you know the new buzz
lightyear movie is coming out because
they just keep keep putting these movies
out and they got rid of tim allen so
they got someone else playing buzz
lightyear i don't even know um
and this is supposed to be i think this
is what is it this is supposed to be the
the real life
buzz lightyear story so this is
buzz lightyear and toy story is a is a
toy
based on a
show
within the movie
and that show within the movie it was
based on a on a real guy
it was not really real obviously and so
this buzz lightyear is about the guy
that the show that the toy was based on
i don't know what's going on um they're
just so basically the movie exists
because they want to sell more toy story
toys that's that's really they said the
movie exists to sell more buzz lightyear
merchandise but they threw this lesbian
kiss scene into this buzz lightyear
movie and uh ben tweeted in response to
that he said disney works to push a not
at all secret gay agenda and seeks to
add queerness to its programming
according to executive producer latoya
raveno
parents should keep that in mind before
deciding whether to take their kids to
see light year which hits theaters this
week children are not adults which
what may be appropriate for adults is
not appropriate for children that this
must be said at all demonstrates that
our society is in a state of moral
collapse
wow ben that's awful stuff
oh wait a second hold on that's um no
never mind he's he's actually no he's
he's directly quoting disney itself so
it's okay right right this no this is
not some crazy conspiracy theory
about disney having a gay agenda no no
that is what disney itself has said
executives at disney have themselves
said we have them on tape okay they're
on video saying that they have a not so
secret gay agenda that's their words so
ben is quoting them directly
oh
okay
but it's still offensive for reasons
that are not entirely clear to me
the other thing is that we know this
scene in light year
was
uh originally
cut from the film
because it was decided by the people by
the filmmakers that they needed to cut
it for time and it just they didn't need
to be in there and it didn't really move
the story along and so they cut it out
right um
they put it back in
directly in response to the anti-groomer
bill in florida and they were very
public about that
there's that's not anyone's
interpretation it's not ben shapiro's
interpretation it's not mine they said
we're gonna put this scene back in there
as kind of a middle finger to the
to all those crazy right wingers in
florida
so it's in there for for political and
ideological reasons that is a fact
and these kinds of scenes are added to
disney films and disney shows because of
their agenda
to promote their ideological viewpoints
that is also a fact they are open about
it they admit it
they're now setting up quotas within the
company for you have to have a certain
amount of lgbt quote representation
in in in the shows now so this is not
you you might want to respond
to somebody making the point that ben's
making or that i'm making
and say well
no you know gay people exist in the
world and so this is just it's just you
know they're it's sometimes they're
gonna be in stories and that's that's
all this is just telling a story and
it's part of the story and that's it
except that's not it
they're not they they added the scene
back in not because they decided it was
necessary for the story they added it
back in for political reasons
so that's the difference
that this stuff is put in there for
ideological and political reasons
not because it's good for the story
and that's why
it's so rare these days that hollywood
puts out
a good film because they don't care
about the story anymore
i mean they still they care about making
money obviously as they always have
but
even before that and certainly before
any consideration about the story it's
about the political messaging
that comes first and foremost
so that's just simply fact if you don't
like it if you don't like anyone
referring to disney's
gay agenda then take it up with disney
they're the ones who said they had it
all right let's see this is from the
hill it says a spates of recent
legislation in republican-controlled
states has brought the topic of
transgender sports competition to the
forefront of the national conversation
now a new poll conducted by the
washington post and university of
maryland found the majority of americans
55 are opposed to allowing transgender
female athletes to compete with other
women and girls in high school sports a
higher proportion 58
reported the same opinion at the college
and professional sports level a total of
500 adults completed the poll between
may 4th and may 17th um representing a
random sample of u.s households while 50
of us 15
percent of respondents had no opinion on
the matter around 30 of americans agree
that transgender women and girls should
be able to compete at any sporting level
now one thing you have to understand
about this they say
55 percent are opposed to quote unquote
transgender females competing against
quote other women and girls
that number is way higher okay already
even even
based on this incredibly biased poll
biased in favor of the left
even there with the way that they
manipulated this and presented it uh
still a majority are opposed
to the trans agenda
but you also have to keep two things in
mind
um number one there's a lot of fear
as we discovered making what is a woman
talking to people even off the record
even off camera
there a lot of people are terrified to
tell anyone what they really believe
maybe they'll tell the people closest to
them in a private setting in the comfort
of their own homes sitting in their own
living room maybe they'll be honest
about it but outside of that people are
terrified
to
speak a little bit of common sense into
this issue
so there's a lot of fear you have to
overcome
that 15 who say they don't know
um
i'd say the majority of them probably
all of them it's less i don't know and
more i'm too afraid to say one way or
another
so really you can add that 15 percent to
the 55 percent but then also keep in
mind though it's the way that these
polls are often worded
now i don't this doesn't have the actual
wording of the poll but the way
certainly if it's worded in a way that
reflects how it's been reported
well in the reporting it says
we're calling them transgender females
first of all
well they're not they're not females
is a is a biological term
so the term trans female doesn't make
any sense
and then they say other should they be
able to compete against other women and
girls which obviously
assumes that they are women also
so you've got that premise which is
embedded into the question itself
and that's going to confuse people
like the the the average person still
when you say the phrase trans woman to
them
they're not even sure what that means
so a trans woman is that a is that a
female who says that she's trans or is
that people don't even know
there's a lot of confusion intentionally
so you get past that confusion
and also the way that this issue is
often presented it's a question of well
should um should and the way people
often think about it is should
transgender people be allowed to compete
in sports or not
that obviously is not the question it's
not i've heard anybody argue that trans
people shouldn't be allowed to compete
in sports
there's no no laws have been passed
outlawing trans people from sports uh
the issue is just whether
females should compete against other
females and males against other males
so fear confusion
wording is is vague all of that stuff
and uh even so you end up still with a
majority of people who are against it
but i think the actual number is
probably i don't know 95
all right let's go to this joe burrow is
the quarterback for the bengals and as
we know when it comes to any important
social issue we always want to hear
from athletes because they're they're
experts and everything you know we need
we need their opinion on all
societal issues um especially gun rights
so here's what joe burrow has to say
about uh the gun rights issue
you know with everything that's going on
if you're not going to outlaw everything
you got to at least make it harder to
to get those
those crazy guns that everybody's using
i don't think you should be able to just
walk in there and buy one you got to be
able to go through you know a rigorous
process to to be able to buy something
like that i think so
you know hopefully
the people that get paid to make those
decisions figure that out
my job is to play football but hopefully
the politicians can figure that one out
well said uh we want to we want to keep
the crazy gun
so the crazy guns we got to keep away
from people
um so it's a crazy
and then but then this the same the the
sane guns the not crazy ones those are
fine so that's that's the dividing line
crazy guns
and i think actually like i'm not a
constitutional scholar but i think
that's in the cons that's in the second
amendment
isn't it it's in there because it says
you know shall not be infringed right to
bear arms but then it also says um
unless it's a crazy gun and then in
which case it can be you know uk don't
have the right to that so that's it
might be an invisible anchor there's a
lot of stuff in invisible link
in the constitution but
you know really you hear that you want
to make fun of joe burrow but that's
as coherent as anybody else
on the gun control side
the only difference is that he he's
delineating between crazy guns
and not crazy guns usually it's scary
guns versus the not as scary guns that's
that's normally how they group these
things
crazy scary kind of the same thing
all right this is from axios it says
nearly a quarter of college students who
wouldn't be friends
rather nearly court of college students
wouldn't be friends with someone who
voted for the other presidential
candidate with democrats far more likely
to dismiss people than republicans
according to the new generation lab
axios polling
says by the numbers five percent of
republicans said they wouldn't be
friends with somebody from the opposite
party compared to 37 percent of
democrats
71 percent of democrats wouldn't go on a
date with someone with opposing views
versus 31 percent of republicans and 30
percent of democrats and seven percent
of republicans wouldn't work with
someone or for someone who voted
differently from them now
i've seen these results
uh
being being posted especially by people
on the right by conservatives
and uh
very sort of proud of themselves and and
saying see we're we're we're the
open-minded ones we'll we'll date
someone it's the democrats who aren't
open-minded
i actually think the democrats have the
right idea here
i think i think they're right
now
be friends with someone who votes
differently from you that's that's one
thing and we have to talk about what we
even mean by friends like i'm talking a
friendly acquaintance
even that now if i want to have a real
uh deep meaningful friendship with
someone
that is going to be very difficult
if they're on the left because we just
have there's really nothing in common
it doesn't mean you can't be a friendly
acquaintance with someone but if you
want to be a if there's a chance for a
real bond in a real friendship even that
is going to be pretty
difficult but dating someone i think
democrats
they're exactly right here
and if you're a republican you should be
happy that most democrats have this view
because they're going to save you
especially if you're single and you're
on the dating scene
the fact that you know if you're if
you're a single man on the dating scene
the fact that according to the poll most
democrat women
will not date you that is that is a good
thing
that's for your own good they're saving
you from themselves just let them do it
but especially when it comes to a
romantic relationship dating someone it
just doesn't work because this goes
beyond this is not just who you vote for
it's
[Music]
we're differentiating by republican and
democrat right now but that's not really
the point
um
the ideological lines
are so deep now
and the gap between the two sides is so
vast
that again it's one thing to be a
friendly acquaintance with someone but
to have a romantic relationship with
somebody
who's on the other side of that vast
cavernous
divide
how is it even possible
you have to have some basic
fundamental things in common you have to
know that has to get down to your your
values
as a human being what do you care most
about most deeply about
opposites attract yes but that
there we're talking about
personality
temperament
uh maybe hobbies and interests and that
kind of thing
my wife has a very different personality
for me very different like it could not
be diametrically
opposite a personality for me
and yet we've been married happily for
uh almost 11 years and that's because
personality is one thing and that keeps
things interesting when you're dating
someone you're with someone who's a
different personality i wouldn't want to
i cannot imagine spending every day
in a house with someone with the same
personality as me that would be a
nightmare
feel sorry for my wife
um
so that's okay that's good
but underneath that you have to have
your you have to have the same values
and priorities in life
because if you don't have those that's
when everything falls apart very quickly
in a relationship
all right
um speaking of relationships that didn't
work out i wanted to play this clip for
you also we played this something
yesterday of amber heard who was
speaking out now and doing interviews um
after losing her defamation case and i
still have a question and i i don't i
don't know the answer to this so maybe
this is a dumb question
but from a legal perspective if you lose
a defamation case because you made
certain claims about somebody
and then you were found liable for
defamation
and then after the defamation case and
you lose it you go out into the public
into the media and repeat the claims
that you just got sued for can you not
get sued again and wouldn't you
almost immediately lose again
so maybe maybe johnny depp will sue her
for another 10 million dollars that
would be pretty funny but here she is
talking about
why we can't trust johnny depp
or what he said in court and i thought
you made an interesting point listen
in the closing arguments the depth
lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
i'm the performer
i had listened to weeks of testimony
uh insinuating that or saying quite
directly that
you know i'm a terrible actress
so i i i'm i'm a bit confused how i
could be both
um
you're a terrible actress because
everyone knew you were acting that's the
point
uh but i i am shocked to learn
that johnny depp so he doesn't have
scissors for fingers i i was totally his
performance in edwards edward scissors
hands scissor hands was so compelling
that like anyone else i thought the
whole this whole time i thought well he
must he is he isn't
embodying
inhabiting this character with
scissor hands he must actually have
scissors for hands and then i noticed
him in other
roles like in pirates of the caribbean
he doesn't have the scissor hands and i
thought well that's
the special effects here are amazing
and i was wondering too watching in the
trial
where are his scissor hands and now we
find out that oh he doesn't he doesn't
actually have them
but amber hurt is right he did convince
us all we were all fooled
to think that he actually had scissor
hands
are you telling me he's not a pirate
either
i just my whole world is collapsing
right in front of me let's get to our
comment section
[Music]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
black metal matter says matt must be uh
matt must be going through a low tea
phase not liking visits to the auto
parts store i love visiting my local
auto parts store uh look listen i just i
prefer i just love rock auto okay i
prefer rock auto that's all just leave
me alone it is it does feel a little
emasculating
every time we're doing a rock auto read
and i have to talk about how much i hate
auto parts stores and not only that but
i'm intimidated i'm intimidated and
scared walking through the auto parts
store but it's true i wouldn't say if it
wasn't true and that's why i use rock
auto so should you
um
isabella says matt you should have you
should have released your book yesterday
june 13th was mtf male to female pride
day
so sad to see a trolling opportunity
missed
is that actually a thing i mean why
would i even be surprised so within
pride month there are specific pride
days for each
identity within the month
i didn't realize that so
but now that i know
for the future more more trolling
opportunities
let's see
stella says oh man matt walsh on a red
carpet is what the world needs right now
no that's not what anybody needs least
of all me
you know what now i'm getting trolled
um on you know on twitter with photos of
me
standing awkwardly in the background
while knowles hams it up on the red
carpet because i'm seeing a lot of these
photos where he's doing this interview
and i'm just kind of standing there
like the loser at the party in the
corner that's not even my fault i was
told to stand there
because
you go through the red carpet and you
have someone who
guides you along actually his mechanic
guiding me along so again blame her for
this
guiding along from one interview to the
next but i have
i have michael knowles in front of me so
it's supposed to be 30 second interviews
and he's doing 30 minute interviews at
each stop and so it's a traffic jam and
all i can do is just stand there
waiting for him to finish
and then i look like
the dork at the end of it so
you have more reasons to keep me away
from red carpets um
let's see i have to disagree with matt's
last point being personally fragile is
another form of being sensitive the
problem is that personally fragile
people ought to be finding ways to
toughen up but instead they often aim to
be to be uh to get gullible empathetic
people and bullies to try and
baby proof the world for them
well no that's my point there's actually
a difference between sensitive and and
fragile you know there's a there's
by definition in reality like those are
two different kinds of people
um we often mislabel fragile people as
sensitive but my point yesterday is that
uh it doesn't matter now because these
words have just become interchangeable
but
in reality there's there's nothing wrong
with being a sensitive person it's
actually good that's a that's a positive
character trait because as i said that's
just another way of saying you're
empathetic that's what sensitive means
you can kind of read people you're aware
of how other people are feeling that
sort of thing
um
but we've used this word to refer to
people who are not really sensitive at
all because they don't they're not they
have no empathy they don't care about
anybody else they have no self-awareness
like look if you have no self-awareness
first of all then you're not a sensitive
person that's the opposite of being
sensitive
um but we take these kinds of people who
are just numb to everybody around them
and only care about themselves
but in their own identity they're
completely fragile and then we label
them sensitive and so that's how this
confusion has come about
um
and finally blake says matt is right
again just had a dinner with my family
and tried to talk about all the ufo
stuff going on right now congressional
hearings details of the tic tac video
the government admitting that they don't
know what these things are etc nobody
really engaged with it and then my
sister-in-law blurts out
has anyone been following the amber
heard trial
everyone starts chiming in and getting
all excited i was quite literally blown
away i just sat there speechless well
this is this is my life every day blake
maybe i should start some sort i should
start a support group
for disenfranchised and rejected ufo
enthusiasts
this is what i live with so you and i we
understand each other's lived
experiences
last night was finally the premiere of
our summer blockbuster tear on the
prairie it's been a long long wait but
that wait is finally over was 18 months
ago when disney canceled gina carano and
the daily wire took action in that
moment not long after disney fired her
we announced that she'd be starring in
and producing
our next original film and here it is
gina's back you'll get to see the proof
with tara on the prairie and you can
watch it right now and see gina like
you've never seen her before fighting
for her family and for what's right the
daily wires mission as you know is to
bring you
films that challenge the viewer without
without any agenda except to make great
movies i'm really excited for everyone
to see this film it's a good
old-fashioned gritty western without the
wokeness so go to dailywire.com gina to
become a member and watch the film
that's
dailywire.comgina right now and the
great content doesn't stop there what is
a woman the book
is out now you saw what is the woman the
movie now it's what is a woman the book
our latest film was a woman was a huge
success enormous success largely due to
you and if you like the film you've got
to read the book which is available
right now the book covers all the stuff
that the film had to leave on the
editing room editing floor and it
explores in greater detail how this
madness permeates every aspect of our
lives so be sure to pick up your copy of
my brand new book what is a woman today
on amazon or wherever you buy books now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
for our cancellation today we head up to
a ranch in montauk new york where horses
and obesity have combined to create a
perfect cancellation
storm perfect conditions for
cancellation nbc news has the important
story it says remy remy bader a
tick-tock star known for her realistic
clothing haul videos i actually have to
stop right there because um we haven't
even finished the first sentence but
realistic clothing haul videos
i'm not sure what a clothing haul video
is i'm even less sure how such a video
could be unrealistic in the first place
do most tick tock stars in the clothing
hall genre use special effects or cgi
is she a pioneer of like gritty
live-action
clothing haul videos these are questions
we don't have time to investigate
because there are larger problems to
deal with continuing
remy barber bader a tick-tock star known
for her realistic clothing haul videos
claimed that during a recent trip with
other influencers a ranch wouldn't allow
her to ride their horses due to her
weight
bader who has more than two million
followers on tick tock was in montauk
new york with other influencers on a
trip organized by the company hampton
water wine over the weekend when she
said she was turned away
now i'm imagining being stuck on a
camping trip or a hiking trip with
tick-tock influencers organized by a
company called hampton water wine and
i'm just filled with dread and despair
at the thought of it
i'd probably just steal one of the
horses and ride off into the sunset
never to be seen again that is assuming
all the horses hadn't been crushed to
death already because that's what this
woman apparently feels she has the right
to do to horses reading more it says in
her initial tic toc post on saturday
bader shared a video of the ranch with
the text over it saying
shout out to deep hollow ranch and
montauk for making me leave because i
weigh over 240 pounds
videos received over 1.5 million views
the caption reads i've rode horses
before and i've never had an issue
she asked them to advertise on their
signs in the future
yes they ought to advertise that on
their signs
this is their fault for not putting
something on their signs indicating that
they'd prefer if their horse's spines
were left intact
because of this oversight remy felt
entitled to publicly bash this small
business as a result the company is now
being flooded with negative yelp reviews
which by the way is a potentially fatal
blow to any business of this size
after launching this attack and
receiving blowback in her own direction
she then claimed that her beef isn't
with the weight limit itself but with
the abrupt and insulting way in which
she was informed of the weight limit
it's not what they said but how they
said it she now claims
and for its part the ranch initially had
no comment instead a teenage employee
took it upon himself to issue his own
rebuttal to this woman and i'll just say
that his
his pr skills could use a little bit of
work let's watch
when you're not a fat you can ride a
deep olive ranch
well
you know that was rude certainly and the
video's been deleted as you'd expect the
ranch has apologized for it and uh
we could probably assume the kid was
fired but remy was determined to get the
last word the next day she clapped back
as the kids say with this rebuttal
um if you don't like me that's fine
but
you know
watch your mouth
two million views uh followers on that
account
in summary a lot of very stupid people
are involved in this story as is so
often the case for the things we talk
about during this segment and during
every other segment of the show but
there are a couple of points i think to
be made here the first is that not every
personal gripe needs to be presented to
the entire world
so let's just pretend for a moment that
remy was completely polite and
accommodating maybe she didn't know that
horses have weight limits maybe she
thought that horses have spines made of
reinforced steel and she just didn't
realize that this was a thing and maybe
she was very understanding when they
informed her of this matter and only
became upset because they were rude and
insulting about it even if that's the
case
why does the world need to be involved
in this dispute why why would you want
the world to be involved aren't you
embarrassed that you were turned away
from a horse ranch because you exceed
the weight limit
if that were me i would go home and pray
that nobody posts anything about the
incident online i certainly wouldn't be
posting about it myself and tell people
about it
but as much as people these days pretend
to care so much about privacy
like we've never talked about privacy as
much as we do in in our society
yet the fact is that most people want
anything but privacy in fact most people
fear privacy
privacy to them is akin to annihilation
annihilation
if they don't post everything online
they'll cease to be they think
they have an answer to the old tree
falling in a forest question if nobody
hears it it doesn't make a sound that's
their opinion just as if nobody knows
about every single thing that's
happening to them
they don't exist that's why people will
willingly post the sorts of things that
people of previous generations would
have died to keep out of public view
there are no boundaries
no shame especially for influencers
whose livelihood depends on making a
spectacle and controversy out of
everything that happens to them
but of course i don't buy that this
person was polite and reasonable and
only upset because of the rudeness of
the staff at the ranch pretty clear at
least initially that she was simply mad
that they wouldn't let her ride the
horses from her perspective it is well
worth sacrificing the physical
well-being of a horse in order to
protect her own emotional well-being
as ben shapiro pointed out in his
reaction to the story these are the
wages of expressive individualism
of course expressive individualism is
the defining philosophy of the modern
age we talk about it all the time on
this show even if not by that name it's
what carl truman elucidates so
brilliantly in his book the rise and
triumph of the modern self he also talks
about it in my film what is a woman
according to expressive individualism a
person is totally defined by
his psychological state
his feelings his self-perception
the primary point of life really the
only point is to protect and affirm and
reinforce that psychological state lives
are lived inwardly everybody is looking
back within themselves all the time
reflecting constantly on their own inner
experience all that matters is the inner
experience
whatever must be done to improve that
experience the one felt inside the one
perceived by the mind
even if it not always reflected in
reality doesn't matter whatever must be
done for its sake
should be done that's all
all that matters to the expressive
individual is their own psychological
comfort
to live authentically
is to live in a way that expresses their
current psychological state and makes
them feel better about it
and if that means crushing a horse it
means crushing a horse
yes you know horses have weight limits
in physical reality but in the mind of
this plus-sized rider on the saddle
there is no weight limit
they can do anything that anybody else
can do
that's how they perceive the world
and themselves and everybody else's job
is to conform to that perception
this mentality obviously has
consequences far far beyond potential
spinal injuries to horses but uh you
know that is one of the that's
collateral damage there's a lot of
collateral damage left behind as the
expressive individual goes about her
life making herself feel better about
herself and never worrying about
anything else least of all horses
and that is why she is today finally
canceled i will leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavolsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire in chief
wake up every morning with our show
morning wire where we bring you all the
news that you need to know in 15 minutes
or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire
[Music]